well materialism from the point of view
of someone interested in obsessed with
consciousness materialism has it's
obvious problem it gives rise to the
so-called hard problem of consciousness
how does subjective experience arise
from objective activities in a brain I
think it's a Mis posed question because
ultimately we have to get rid of this
duality materialism can't account for
subjective experience and idealism can't
account for the the material world but
all easily can experience in any way
practicing different experiences to look
into the nature of the universe help at
all well here's my adventures at the
moment I would say I'm a bit obsessed
I'm glad to be invited on this panel
because I'm a bit obsessed in an
ignorant exploring kind of way about the
stuff of the universe so one thing I
tend to do this time of year it would be
in my greenhouse late at night I've been
working hard all day like the song goes
out and sure sure gets burned at night
and I have a spliff and sit there and
start thinking now one of the ways this
will go will be okay do that meditation
thing I'm used to drop duality I can't
do it intellectually but I can do it
experientially self disappears into
stuff there's just stuff happening now
that's fine as I said it's an experience
but I don't know how to make that work
as a kind of a theory and what I then
can start to think about one direction
to go is well where does the material
fit in this if you think about a
scientist or me you know doing
experiments and so on all you've ever
got is somebody's experience even if
that's looking into a Hadron Collider or
looking at the readouts of of
instruments so that that puts me over to
the idealism side but then I think we'll
how can we agree and you've both touched
on this in a way because we agree
certainly about mathematics on another
planet you know other aliens wouldn't
call them electrons and protons but
they'd presumably discover something
similar so I'm forced into a kind of
absolutely no idea what this stuff is
but we are agreeing a
somehow misses a very deep I don't know
here's another thank you for that thank
you for that
ignorance it's it's very nice to be
applauded rig nerds here's another one
this is another one founded in
meditation and I've only recently begun
to explore this there's a classic Zen
Cohen that says look behind your own
face and until recently I thought that
was just some kind of metaphor because a
lot of Cohen's actually take you off in
all kinds of weird directions but I
found myself on a recent retreat
literally doing that it was very very
weird experience because it felt as
though I was looking from the outside in
as well as looking from the inside out
and it we had different kinds of
weirdness depending where I was whether
I was just in silent meditation or
walking around in the silent retreat but
interestingly what I saw has been
described it's I mean supposed to be
ineffable you can't really say much
about it the best description I've ever
read was a man who was poisoned by
morphine in Thailand and he woke up in a
horrible hospital with dirt everywhere
and you know very happy and content and
he said it's as though the back of my
head has been sawn off and the hind is
the dazzling darkness now my experience
was of seeing kind of an intense
nothingness nothingness with a
nothingness that somehow seemed to be
alive and I guess this may be something
like what people are talking about the
ground of being or something of that
kind
I don't know but experientially it's
really really interesting to explore
these things but this gave the
impression that it is out of this alive
nothingness that comes behavior and
talking and all the kinds of things and
the duality of the illusion itself and
all the other dualisms that come about
but but but what is it I mean you know
it's to say something completely
unhelpful really there's a kind of
something nothing out of which
everything comes doesn't really get you
anywhere but I throw out these
experiences in case they're at all
relevant and really my only pitch is I'm
really struggling with this one
did you know that the Institute of arson
ideas also has a podcast philosophy for
our times brings you the biggest ideas
from the leading thinkers around the
world every week search for philosophy
for our times and subscribe today on
your favorite podcast platform
SoundCloud or iTunes to make sure you
never miss an episode